I'm wondering if you can share a story
leaving out any names or identifying
details about a challenging time either
as a producer and actor a writer and how
it made you grow for lack of a better
word but it really taught you a lot
about either working with people about
yourself about how things work sure I'll
give you two okay two quick ones a good
one in a bad one oh good so working on
the feature you know I was tailing all
the the cast so I was dealing with
agents and managers up you know summer
your big-time agencies and management
companies and I'm someone that was like
I'll send you everything if you want to
do it awesome fantastic if you don't
okay it's not a big deal and everyone
was from you know the top a level
agencies to the bottom ones were nice
and sweet there was just one just one
where it was a communication error and
we're going back and forth and we just
needed an answer so I was like and if it
was fine it wasn't like if you wanted if
your client wants to do this awesome if
they don't just just let us know because
we have to move forwards production
starts yada yada yada long story short I
end up getting pretty reamed out on the
phone and was just like you know i took
my licks I did it I still don't I didn't
do anything wrong I didn't cross any
boundaries I didn't do anything it
caught somebody on a bad day it wasn't
an argument it wasn't a fight it was me
getting yelled at and so then I reached
out to the other guys in the film a
console them what happened and one of
the directors pulled me aside was like
it's you know that's one person out of
probably 500 that you talked to so don't
let that affect what's going on and it
has and it's just a story that it's like
you know he caught someone on a bad day
and I don't hold anything against that
person and to be honest they probably
don't even remember speaking to me and
it was just one of those moments that it
was like oh I guess there is that stare
because I was like all the stereotypes
about Hollywood is wrong everyone's nice
and everyone's cool and everyone wants
to talk to you then that one was like um
and felt like eeyore just like down in
the dumps for the day but it ended up
working out for the best for everyone
involved for the person we wanted their
clients for us I mean it was it came
about the wrong way but the end product
ended up working and then on the
positive side
I am I right for a company a script
development company in production
up-and-coming production company and I
got to have a meeting about my script
with a pretty big name producer and I
thought he was going to come and who's
worked in business for more years that
I've been alive so if I was gonna come
in and be like this is garbage this is
what you need to do if you ever want to
get the sole yadda yadda yadda and he
basically came in and gave compliments
and gave notes and his notes are more
like take these if you want to use them
you don't have to this is just what I'm
saying and it was very cool to have
someone that has more experience than I
ever will if I live my whole life out
here to talk to me like I'm on his level
when I'm not in any way shape or form
and I was like they learned from that as
well to that it's just like Oh people
just like what they do and they're
willing to help people that are
up-and-coming and whatever it is they're
trying to pursue it was really really
cool and I've told not without saying
the name I've told a lot of people that
and it's you know from the comedy world
to like Oh big name people are nice too
it was it was really really kind of
rewarding and gave me a lot of
confidence for what I was doing so if
someone else were let's because it's
happened it's happened to me I've called
for interviews and I've experienced that
same situation and what do you advise
someone that's going through that in the
moment cuz she it dissipates after a
while and then talk about the bad part
yeah the bad part and cuz I think it
will happen every once in a blue moon
you know it was one of those things that
it was like I got off the phone first of
all I was like out at the time i was
actually shooting something so i was on
set for something dealing with another
project not like i'm doing with so many
projects it's just one of those right
we're pretentious thing to say oh no
nobody i suture yeah over Laos yeah a
long time something overlaps like I was
in the right mood and I would just say
that I was dealing with like five people
in this camp mm-hmm and a bunch of them
had the same name so it was already very
confusing to me and I guarantee just
something got lost in translation in
between emails and phone calls and there
were a couple missed appointments you
know not
and so it just happened where I was like
someone felt that I was going behind
normal protocol yeah and that's what
happened with me too yeah so i reamed
yet i got reamed and it was and it was
just like i did i wrote a very
apologetic email and you know they wrote
me an email back that that was like not
apologizing but kind understanding they
were over the top a little bit with a
nice so wasn't bad in like I said I
never said anything I just bit my tongue
it was just like all right this is gonna
happen I'm learning right it's fine I'll
remember it forever and they like I said
they haven't thought twice about it it
was like a Hollywood hazing oh yeah nice
there we go i was a Hollywood haze okay
how's a cool wait up that was a good
spin it was a Hollywood hazy good old
kappa delta hazing out there right and
you didn't you dustin yourself off and
you said now cuz then it makes you not
as afraid i think to take another chance
because you're like okay I've been
through it well and you know it was a
higher level you know they carried a lot
of respect so I never wanted to have a
bad image or someone may beat them down
the road be like hold on did I yell at
you on the phone once X amount of years
ago right but it like I said there were
other people you know kind of on that
same professional level as this other
person that treated me like I was you
know someone they've been working with
the whole time so it's like I said wrong
time wrong day caught someone in bad
mood you know right and you dusted
yourself off mmm it's like she hit I was
a parked car and she hit it two people
have to make a car accident right she
just happened to hit me while I was
parked so
you